- What's up everybody?
We are back with Chance
the Rapper, Angie Martinez,
and DJ Cassidy.
(crowd applauding)
So this year marks 50 years,
since hip hop was officially born
at a house party in the Bronx,
and to celebrate its time
for a hip hop edition
of "Undercover Covers."
(upbeat music)
♪ Undercover Covers ♪
(Kelly laughing)
Well, Lord, are you a fan of hip hop?
Are you here?
(heavenly tones)
Oh.
- [Godd] Oh, you know I am Kelly.
It's me, the G-O-double-D and the hizzy.
What's up girl?
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm good, how are you?
- [Godd] I'm good, the second D is silent.
Don't worry about that.
Let's play a game.
- Yes.
- [Godd] All right now here's
what's going to happen.
I'm gonna slowly reveal a
famous hip hop album cover
on the big screen there,
one tile at a time.
- Okay, okay.
- [Godd] Now, when you
know the name of the artist
you're gonna hit your button and guess.
If you're right, you're gonna hear this.
(bell dings)
And you can also name
the title of the album
for a bonus point.
But if you're wrong
(buzzer beeps)
I'm gonna keep revealing
that album for the other team
but your team's gotta sit there
and marinate for a minute.
You just gotta sit there and take it.
You can't say nothing, okay?
- Okay. Okay.
- [Godd] Kelly and DJ Cassidy,
you're playing to win a prize
for the left side of the audience.
Make some noise left side.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Godd] And Chance and Angie,
you're playing for the right.
Come on right.
- All right, all right.
(audience cheering)
Calm down right side. Calm down.
- [Godd] All right, let's go,
let's play some games here.
Here is album cover number one.
- You going down, Kelly.
- Mm-hm?
- [Godd] Come on now, slowly revealing.
There you go.
- I don't see anything, what's happening?
- [Godd] There's nothing
yet. That's all right.
- That's Tupac, that's Tupac.
That's Tupac.
Hello?
(bell dinging)
- [Godd] It is Tupac!
- That's "All Eyes on Me."
- [Godd] It is "All Eyes on Me."
- [Godd] We're gonna give both.
- Very fast, very fast.
- She also-
- Very fast.
- [Godd] She said both.
I heard it. I heard it.
- Yeah, I said both.
- [Godd] God hears all.
- That's two points
for me, zero for Kelly.
Zero for Kelly.
- [Godd] Zero for Kelly.
- Okay. Okay.
- [Godd] Just rub it in.
Ooh, I like her.
She's got some spunk.
That's what I'm talking about
- Very impressive Angie.
- [Godd] She's off the
chain. All right, here we go.
Here's the next Undercover Cover.
Check this out now.
One tile at a time.
- Wait a minute, it
- [Godd] Could be anything now.
- Oh, oh, I think I know this. Oh gosh.
- [Godd] Now if you know,
you know what to do.
- I know, but I don't wanna.
- [Godd] You talk the talk.
You gotta walk the walk.
You gotta press that button if you know.
Come on now.
(button ringing)
- Get it, get it.
- [Godd] There it is.
- Eminem?
- That is Eminem.
(bell dinging)
- [Godd] It is Eminem!
(audience cheering)
- "Marshall Mathers LP?"
- [Godd] That's it Chance. You got it.
- We're going easy.
- Okay. Okay.
- You made me so proud.
You make me so proud.
- Alright, we let you have a couple.
We let you have a couple.
- I mean yeah, okay.
- [Godd] They let you have a couple.
- Cassidy, you're a DJ, you
should be ashamed of yourself.
- [Godd] Got ourselves a game here.
- We let you have a couple
rounds guys, let's go.
- [Godd] Alright, everybody calm down.
All right, here's your
next Undercover Cover.
Take a look.
Show it slow now. Take your time.
- Oh I already know!
This is "The Chronic", Dr. Dre!
(bell dings)
- [Godd] It's unbelievable!
It is "The Chronic" and it is Dr. Dre.
And you're killing it over there.
- It's the frame.
It's the little frame.
- [Godd] You're killing it over there.
- You saw the frame at the bottom?
- I saw the frame at the bottom.
Sorry guys. Sorry guys.
- Plenty of time. There's plenty of time.
- I mean, this is almost
embarrassing for them.
- There's plenty of time.
- This is not.
- [Godd] Nothing but a G thing.
The G means me.
The G-O-double-D.
Alright, we got ourselves a game here.
- Okay.
- [Godd] Chance and Angie,
you're just killing it.
Kelly and DJ Cassidy, you got zero,
big zero there on the board.
- Plenty of time.
- [Godd] But that's okay
because this next one
is worth five points.
- Oh my God.
- [Godd] Let's take a look.
- You always do this to me!
- [Godd] Yes I do.
- This is how she stole
the game last time.
- [Godd] Pray on it, girl.
Pray on it. Pray on it.
Here's the next one.
- Chance, this is how they
steal the game from you.
Be very close, pay -
- That's not God.
- [Godd] Pay attention now.
(Kelly laughing)
(button ringing)
- [Godd] How dare you doubt
me, how dare you doubt me.
We're in the game. We're in the game.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
- That was Outkast! That's Outkast!
That's Outkast.
- I hit it first Ange.
- [Godd] I did see,
I will say that I did see
that DJ Cassidy hit it first.
I will agree with you on that.
What is it?
- OutKast, "Stankonia"
but let's do a redo.
- [Godd] Put some stank on it.
(audience cheering)
(bell dinging)
- Okay, what's the score now?
- I didn't think we'll get it either.
- [Godd] However, this next
one is worth 10 points.
- This is how they get,
this is ridiculous.
- [Godd] Okay so here we go.
Please reveal that album cover.
- Mm-hm, all right.
I think I know this already.
Wait a minute.
That's Ready to Die!
That's Biggie.
Ready to Die. Ready to Die.
That's B-I-G.
- [Godd] You got it. It's Biggie.
It's Ready to Die.
(Angie screams)
- She's incredible at this.
- I'm retiring.
(intense music)
- [Godd] That very serious sound effect
means we have time for one
more and this one is worse.
It's worth 50 points in
honor of 50 years of hip hop.
Here is the final.
- Maybe this is really
your time, you know.
- [Godd] Undercover Cover.
Slowly reveal.
(button ringing)
- Oh, I know it, I know it.
That's "Miseducation of Lauryn Hill."
- [Godd] It is "The
Miseducation of Lauryn Hill"
and unbelievably.
- I said it first. I said it first.
- But she hit it first.
- I said it first!
(closing buzzer chimes)
- [Godd] That's it.
- Listen, if you guys...
- Can I tell you something right now?
This is the only record I recognize.
(Angie and Kelly laughing)
Here's the thing.
What we're gonna do in
honor of 50 years of hip-hop
and my love for Chance and Angie,
because they really did kick our asses.
- As long as we're clear,
as long as we're clear.
- We did not technically win.
So they're gonna win the game.
But everyone's a winner.
Everyone's a winner!
(audience cheering)
Hailed as the most aesthetically
pleasing blender out there,
the Beast is thoughtfully designed
and meticulously engineered
to be both easy to use
and also extremely powerful.
With a one minute smart blending cycle,
it can also prepare
nutrient rich infusions
when combined with the
accompanying hydration system.
And everyone is going home
with the Beast Blender and
Hydration system today.
(Kelly hooting)
(audience applauding)
- I'm just glad I got one right.